so you want to be a content creator well
that means you need Charisma you got to
learn filmmaking technical skills
editing there's so much time and effort
that goes into creating content but what
if I told you there was a solution what
if I told you that by harnessing the
power of AI procedurally generated
dialogue environments Unreal Engine code
scripting you could have all that power
of a content creator at your fingertips
well I'm happy to announce that I Sam
Gorski finally figured it out I cracked
the code with my content button if I
press this I will be creating content
instantly Anything could happen when I
press this button
what is content is content even good is
content just like the vegetable oil of
art it's something that is like
classifies as a food product and has
calories but it is so devoid of any
flavor or value there's garbage out
there everywhere these influencers
creating relationships sharing stories
appearing in the real world virtual
influencers they're so forgettable and
why are they forgettable well it's
because they're basically just a 3D
renderer with a marketing team writing
the description text of their Instagram
post it's like the facade of an
influencer it's the facade of something
that's real It's the final frontier of
content or is it perhaps there is an
even finaler Frontier to reach and
that's what I want to accomplish what if
we could create a true virtual
influencer that isn't being curated by a
human imagine Tick Tock but worse and
but kind of funnier why why why it's to
kind of show how easy it is to make most
of the stuff you see out there basically
we're just trying to add to the pile
here's my goal take the human touch away
from this as far as possible we have ai
tools under our belts we're getting into
unreal we got some real-time stuff we
got character animation tools so much
stuff in our belts right now I'm gonna
let the computer make the content for me
I'm not gonna make the content you know
at the end of this we have to actually
have a little piece of software with a
button that says content oh my God
we hopped on a call with my buddy Brad
he's really good at unreal he knows
Blueprints and some scripting stuff but
he knows it on a professional level that
we don't that yeah you know who knows
what will happen but the idea is to try
and create this procedural system that
can effectively take a text-based script
and then parse that out into the
different elements we need for a you
know five to ten second long social
media snippet are you talking about like
the AI dungeon like that hormone
storytelling like how that just goes
like nuts as it goes on yes and most AIS
end up doing that and so AI dungeon
those guys are awesome it's hilarious so
what we're working with is the same like
algorithm that they're using this is
what I tell the AI to do I say hey
there's a character named ZZ who loves
to post daily stories on his social
media account below I want you to list a
bunch of suggested elements in his
script such as a suggested location a
suggested mood some suggested dialogue
camera angle like is it a selfie
whatever and then also uh suggest if
he's dancing or not in this
parameterizing it for like unreal helps
a lot exactly and so we chatted with him
about like the overarching like
architecture of how we're gonna put this
system together and he had a lot of
wisdom on that and Brad's gonna try and
create a piece of unreal logic that will
take our input text and parse the
different parameters and send those off
to the different parts of unreal to you
know load in the location load in the
animation and now he's gonna run off and
start prototyping some stuff that uh
we'll get to see next week so I'm
excited
I mean catch you later peace all right
it's a lot of stuff it's a lot of stuff
man okay well so I just spoke with Brad
basically we just walked through like
the foundation systems that are being
built out it's easy to say hey let's
make in the AI influencer right it's
easy to say that but what we're doing
right now is we are breaking that down
into its individual components where is
this being filmed what room is it in
where are we so we need to know that we
have to be able to dynamically shift
that depending on our AI script we need
to know where the camera is going to be
is this a selfie is this going to be a
first person angle is is this going to
be set on the ground or a table nearby
we have to be able to go through all
these little things here and have this
script dynamically generate everything
obviously we are limited by the amount
of assets we're throwing at it like the
AI could obviously generate any type of
location in the world but for us to able
to actually show it you know it has to
be built so the best proof of concept
here is to have this set within a
virtual influencer house those big
mansions that they like Cokes teens from
around the world to come and live at and
then make social media posts from like a
programming standpoint actually makes
things a lot more achievable right now
where it's like here's one big map
and uh we're gonna set you know zones
and Bounds for each like room and
location but basically keeps it all
within this one massive level Brad is
handling some of that top level stuff
right now camera animation character
animation and what I'm focused on right
now is basically everything from the
neck up and one of the biggest hurdles
is getting the character to
automatically lip sync to an audio file
because that's what we're going to need
to do we have to be able to throw audio
at this character and then he's gonna
have to say it so our favorite boys at
made up they got this thing called
Oculus you may have heard of it they
have a plug-in where it listens to audio
and it tries to get the visemes what
what are visemes I've talked about it
before it's a list of the shapes of your
lips when you speak it's like the
difference between think and Duck or put
your lips make individual shapes with us
and it can listen to audio and predict
the lip shape that you're making and it
does this in real time so all I do is
plug in an audio file and it does the
rest take a look I was just out in the
front yard and I saw a really cool
looking bird I'm not sure what kind of
bird it was but it was so pretty I'm
going to go look it up on my phone and
see if I can find out more about it so
not perfect but pretty good everything's
together it's moving I need to go
through and take one pass to make things
more nuanced and then see how it really
is from there but what's nice about this
system is I can drop any audio file I
want in there right now and it just will
do it that's a huge deal but for this
project and anything else we're doing so
we have what the character is going to
say and the mouth movements associated
with that but now we need a voice to
bring our influencer to life and it
can't just be any voice it has to be a
voice appropriate for ziera Vega
[Music]
or non-binary incentives rapid social
media influencer who posts long-winding
stories of their everyday Adventures or
at least that's what this GP T3
algorithm is told to do so in order to
create Zero's AI voice we will be using
dscript yes I did get banned from using
the service yes okay yeah I made a new
account no big deal my female voice
impression is not very good so I just
said hey Jordan you know you're a social
media influencer already so why not go
deep into that stereotype yourself make
it funny I'm not an influencer all the
time I'm not always influencing peeps
stay here and talk for 10 for 10 minutes
and my influencer voice and now I have
to be happy silly sad horrified it's
gonna be interesting it makes me sweaty
it's a lot to think about I was out in
the yard today playing with my dog and I
saw a really funny sight I saw squirrel
up in the tree I think we're headed for
some real dark times and we need to be
prepared for it I know a lot of people
think I'm crazy I'll do better next time
I just need some help
can you help me
perfect
oh it's weird you think that's good yeah
it's perfect it's perfect
I mean that's all just AI gibberish too
like I'm like I'm not responsible for
anything she just said well most of our
individual systems are working the lip
sync's working character animations
working dancing camera angles locations
we have a map there's even an animated
time of day as well where it can choose
what time this social media post is
being filmed so everything's there
in pieces but right now the next task is
to put it all together you know to be
taking the cables yep we're going we're
putting our head underneath the desk
getting everything
plugged in and I think we could have a
V1 running in the next day or two if
things go well
[Music]
now it's pretty nuts what's also kind of
nuts is how language written language
specifically kind of develops to support
the recipes for beer like 5 000 years
ago and I learned that thanks to today's
sponsor audible a history of the world
in six glasses it's actually a pretty
fascinating historical take at how
technology and civilization has
developed thanks to six different drinks
I can count I promise the book covers
how civilization goes through time
transforming and evolving as these
drinks have also changed it went up to
the Greeks who had wine and then the
spirits you know heart a stuff that
helped all the sailors get across the
ocean and have a good time where's my
rum gone and then it culminated with
coffee tea and then Coca-Cola it's
pretty nuts how these drinks have
actually changed the course of human
history and this book tells you all
about it so what is Audible you've heard
me talk about it before so chances are
you already know but essentially it's an
all-in-one location for your favorite
audiobooks and they've got thousands of
titles to choose from as an audible
member you get one free title per month
and that always accounts for books that
usually cost more than your subscription
just saying it's a great way to save
money if you want to listen to some
audiobooks and of course there are
audible Originals they come with your
subscription and you just get them
whenever you want and if you're into
podcasts well guess what you can listen
to all your podcasts in the audible app
as well keep it all contained you can
download your titles for offline
listening or if you don't have that much
space on your phone you can just stream
them all it's very convenient the
audible app makes it incredibly
convenient to listen to these titles
whenever you want for instance I love
listening to books when I'm you know
doing the dishes or walking my dogs so
of course if you want to listen to this
title you can get a free 30-day trial by
going to audible.com Corridor crew or
just simply texting Corridor crew it's a
500 500 again that is audible.com
Corridor crew or you can text it 500 500
just say quarter crew in the text and
you'll be good
welcome to Sam's crazy Corner each time
you see a shot or an angle like this you
know it's about to get very weird we got
a V1 we've finally taken all these
puzzle pieces all these all these
systems and we have them connected and
it is technically
working let me warn you ahead of time
what you're about to see is strange it
is shocking it is scary it is janky but
it's completely
procedural and generated by an AI
I just slept in the bathtub and bumped
my booty have you ever bumped your butt
before it really hurts maybe I should
get a Band-Aid my favorite type of
Band-Aids have cool colors and patterns
on them I always stock up on them when I
can you have to make sure to dry the
skin before applying them or else they
fall off
[Laughter]
I've been down in the basement for hours
looking through all of my old stuff I
found this really old journal from when
I was a kid and it was so interesting to
read it was like reliving my past life
sometimes I get so lost and thought that
I forget what's going on around me it's
like my mind is its own world okay so as
you see it's super janky but the pieces
are there there's all sorts of stuff
that's like going wrong right now like
sometimes the character will like spawn
in in the camera's position they'll
start glitching out and also you know
the character isn't like looking at the
camera which we need to we need to add a
whole system to make sure you know hey
let's actually look at the lens
um there's lots of little things like
this but what you're watching here is a
procedural animation we basically go hey
what's the location we have a boundary
we have a box that bounds that location
and spawns the character within it it
looks at the mood it changes the facial
expression of the character the dialogue
itself has a whole system where we're
using loudness detection to motivate
cuts the big goal right now is to kind
of iron out some of these bugs here so
it starts feeling a little bit more
smoother right now it's quite chaotic
but you know once again this is a system
that's designed to handle any input we
give it we can plug this script in and
anything can happen anywhere here and it
will always be different each time you
watch it
I'm noticing patterns beginning to form
this AI is very negative let's just say
that it likes to be angry and it likes
to be disappointed it likes to complain
I've noticed for some reason it's so
hard to get fun happy posts out of it
disappointed I can't believe my date
stood me up I'm like oh my gosh basement
scared I'm feeling scared right now I'm
in the basement by myself and I heard a
noise I'm gonna go check it out wish me
luck I've been thinking a lot about life
lately what's the point of it all why
are we here I just don't know
I'm gonna keep thinking about this until
I find an answer it's just it just
starts bringing me down because the
thing is like I know this is like
garbled AI but the moment you put them
into a string there's a psychological
thing that starts happening where I'm
like like you just can't help but
connect these thoughts and the more it
starts pumping out these negative ones
you're like oh you start feeling bad for
this non-existent AI character life is
confusing I don't I feel like I'm
drifting through life without any
purpose like bedroom sad I'm so sad I
want to lay in bed and cry all day I
don't want to face the world don't you
think it would make sense for her to be
scared that you've trapped her in this
house
so what I've done is I have trapped this
AI influencer in this house you know if
I did that to a person that would be bad
if I did it to a computer well they
shouldn't be able to complain correct
that's the idea I was just thinking
about how I really wanted to go out
tonight but then I remembered that I'm
stuck at home I'm really just
disappointed that I can't go out and
have fun next post mood angry I was just
thinking about how I really hate this
place I hate the way it smells I hate
the way it looks
I just feel so angry all the time yeah
I'm serious it's very intense having to
read these I I feel like I'm kind of
going crazy a little bit because
everything I know it shouldn't make
sense and that these posts are
completely disjointed but I can't help
but like feel like these are being
written by an actual like being I mean
these AIS work in the same way that our
brains do you know they have neurons
just like our brains have neurons so
kind of if you think about it it is a
person
all right so we showed you the B1 this
is where the V2 is at it's a lot
smoother
I'm so excited to show you my new Garden
I've been working on it for weeks and
it's finally starting to come together
I've got all sorts of different flowers
vegetables and herbs growing it's so
satisfying to see everything come to
life do you like gardening what are some
of your favorite plants
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ridiculous I'm lying in bed thinking
about life
insect creature it's kind of depressing
when you think about it too much but
it's also strangely comforting knowing
that everything is temporary means that
nothing really matters in the grand
scheme of things we're all just
temporary beings in a temporary
table like what is this
[Music]
wow looks like she's down
I dude I feel so influenced okay this is
looking great there's one little camera
bug uh overall I'm pretty happy with it
like I'm okay on some glitchiness
between shots because like literally we
each time the camera is supposed to cut
like everything moves to a new spot it's
pretty smooth it's watchable you can
understand it you can see the characters
speak the dancing's Great
today's the big day we've been
diligently working to get most of these
bugs fixed I think they're fixed but the
point is like it is time to start
releasing this into the world I'm going
to run it and if this is If This truly
works I'll be able to hit play and not
have to worry about anything hi everyone
welcome to my home my name is Sierra and
I just wanted to say thanks for watching
my videos if you're new here be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss any of my
crazy Adventures
there's something wrong with the audio
right now uh it's a little weird how the
character was on the table but whatever
welcome to my game room whenever I want
to play video games this is where I come
I also have a pool table and a dartboard
but I don't use them as much
okay I think I screwed up one thing I
wonder if I could fit a trampoline in
here
I thought it was work okay I'm getting
cut uh I'm I'm a little confused right
now what's going on here uh
just when you think everything
everything's supposed to work uh
suddenly it doesn't so
um that's cool
uh I think this is Peter's fault I'm
gonna blame him
two hours later last we spoke it was
ready to go
well yeah except I hadn't really looked
at it all weekend and I thought it was
working on Friday
and then there was like a tweak or two
made and I don't even know if it was if
it was those tweaks or if it had been
broken all along and I just never
noticed it when you're doing this kind
of stuff like sometimes you make a
change to one little system and then it
ripples throughout the logic of how
everything else works and like one small
change can kind of break it all and
you're like okay well sometimes you need
that small change in order to make it
even work in the first place and so now
it's in a state where it's the most
broken it's been so far
um it was so so so so close I don't know
what this is I don't know I don't know I
she's fighting back this is not the AI
is dumb it's like this is not a real
creature or being
if their soul is resisting this well are
you mad at her for this I'm not no Dean
I'm not I'm not
cut on the desk moment that Everyone
likes to get so here we go I'm just
gonna do it here we go
oh you're so close yep uh we'll see if
we can get this fixed and working I know
what the path is to get it working
seems like a simple path
[Music]
I had to rebuild a bunch of stuff we
basically we had to go in and just
destroy that we had to tear it apart
break it down thankfully it was pretty
straightforward like we know how this
stuff works pretty well at this point to
uh to make big changes quickly yeah
there's an occasional hiccup or two like
that
it's all rusty
anyway so yeah it's generally working uh
we have an occasional glitch or two here
oh well but the things I really want to
get this out into the world and it's not
truly ready until we have one last thing
at the very beginning we're talking
about making a Content button we wanted
to hit a button and have it make content
however the way it was built you know
that's not quite the case right now
right now we're generating the script
from the gpt3 but then we then have to
create a spreadsheet out of that script
so that unreal can handle and parse
everything you also need to isolate the
dialogue from the script and generate a
track plug-in so it's well it's not that
much work in fact it's only like 10
15 minutes of work so it's not a Content
button right now but it's certainly like
a like an accelerated like we get to
skip the line when it comes to making
content so it's a Content fast pass
Peter like I brought you here today
because I knew that you would be the
perfect fit for helping us fix this last
step in the process you are the
literally the one person who would allow
me to press a button and content would
just suddenly appear on the internet
whatever you need to make your vision
come true I'm getting
foreign
I got it oh okay you heard that okay
just I was just making sure it still
works
give me a couple minutes okay
I've been thinking a lot about AI lately
and I'm really curious about it I know a
lot of people are afraid of AI but I
think it has the potential to do a lot
of good I'm not saying we should all
become robots but I think AI can help us
in ways we never thought possible what
do you think everything that Sierra
posts about and comments about is all
stuff that either you're suggesting or
it's coming up with like these these are
story lines that it continues to build
upon based off of all the engagements it
has if you want to check it out yourself
head over to zierra x-i-e-r-r-a
underscore Vega on Instagram or Tick
Tock and leave a comment send a DM uh
it's interactive as well feel free to
ask a question leave a suggestion of
where zero should visit you know it's
it's very open-ended have at it also
I hate to you know do two pushes like
this but if you could subscribe to this
channel as well that'd be pretty cool
too